I almost never take vacation but I
decided this weekend I would get out of
town with sweet little Alisa and
disconnect from the news for a few days
and even miss a show something I almost
never do on Columbus Day and during that
brief little time away the world blew up
Hamas terrorists launched the worst
attack on the state of Israel in 50
years committed all sorts of crimes
against civilians killing more than 700
Israelis and injuring at least 2500
people I'm sure the numbers are higher
that was as of yesterday evening now the
Israeli government is understandably
retaliating against Hamas in Gaza the
conflict will almost certainly draw in
more combatants Iran which funded the
attack the us as the global hedgemon at
least for now and who knows how many
other countries thousands of civilians
will be killed with a global order
already threatened by a rising China
Rising bipolarity the first major war in
Europe since the 1940s we could be on
the brink of world war and even a
restructuring of the international
order the most gut-wrenching part of the
whole thing is the attack the initial
attack on Israeli civilians by Hamas the
second most gut-wrenching part is the
destruction particularly of civilians in
the war that will now inevitably
follow but only slightly less
gut-wrenching is the knowledge that we
had peace in the Middle East just 3
years
ago 3 years ago historic peace in the
Middle East throughout the world really
but
especially and most implausibly in the
most fraught region on Earth and then we
just gave it
up we just gave it away we got a new
leader of the world supposedly for the
purpose of restoring normaly
because 3 years ago politics it was so
abnormal yeah it was abnormal and we did
we did get that return to normaly that
campaign promise I'm sorry to say is
exactly what we got I'm Michael nolles
this is the Michael nolles
[Music]
Show
while the world burns the United Nations
is concerned
about the plight that they face we'll
get to that in just a moment first
though you remember when Joe Biden gave
Iran billions of dollars not that long
ago this would have been in uh July Joe
Biden gave $10 billion to Iran from Iraq
and then month after that he he approved
the unfreezing of $6 billion
in Iranian oil revenues and uh then Iran
funded the largest terror
attack perhaps ever in the state of
Israel uh certainly the largest Act of
war in 50 years that threatens to plunge
the entire world into a conflict uh here
is the US Secretary of State explaining
himself with regard to the uh the funds
that you mentioned um that um uh were
released to were made available to Iran
for humanitarian purposes uh as part of
uh getting Americans back who are being
held and detained in Iran let's be very
clear about this and it's deeply
unfortunate that some are playing
politics when so many lives have been
lost and Israel remains under attack the
facts are these no US taxpayer dollars
were involved these were Iranian
resources uh that uh Iran had
accumulated from the sale of its oil uh
that were stuck in a bank in South Korea
they have had from day one under our law
under our sanctions the right to use
these monies for humanitarian purposes
they were moved from one account uh to
another in another country to facilitate
that use as of now not a single uh uh
dollar has been spent uh from that
account and again uh the account is
closely regulated by the US Treasury
Department so it can only be used for
things like food medicine uh medical
equipment that's what this is about
everything is wrong about his statement
and I don't think he's a stupid man the
charitable read on what he's saying is
that he's just really really stupid but
I don't think he's really stupid so I
think he's being deceitful here he's
saying on the one hand look this isn't
American money we got nothing to do with
this okay this ain't US taxpayer dollars
this is Iran's
money that we've been controlling and
that is highly regulated by the US
government but it's not us we're not
involved at all but we actually control
the whole thing so we didn't really do
anything and we bear no culpability but
we're the ones who unfroze it and but we
told them that's the first part it's so
ridiculous if you are the
possessor if you are the controller of
funds and then you open those funds up
for use by Iran you bear some
culpability for what happens with those
funds so and he anticipates this so so
he then pivots and he says but we told
them this money that was already there
is that we had no control over we told
them you can only use this for
humanitarian
purposes does the US Secretary of State
not understand that money is
fungible does the US Secretary of State
say not understand that if you if you've
got a a derelict brother let's say your
derelict brother is a a drug addict and
you've got he says hey man can you spot
me a hundred bucks and your derck
brother he's got he's got 100 bucks and
you say okay I'll give you a 100 bucks
but you can only use this for food you
can only use this for shelter you can't
use this for drugs you you give him the
money what's he going to do he's
obviously going to go out and buy drugs
but he can come back to you and tell you
with a straight face no I didn't use
your hundred bucks for the drugs I used
my hundred bucks for the drugs and then
I use your hundred bucks for the food in
the shelter that I otherwise would have
used my hundred bucks for so it's not
really I didn't I separated all the
dollars out so don't worry your dollars
didn't go for the bad thing only my
dollars did and my dollars were able to
go for the bad thing because I had your
dollars to spend on the good thing so it
you bear no responsibility wasn't your
money money is
fungible just all gets kind of mixed
together and so obviously if you're
giving Iran $10 billion $6 billion $16
billion obviously that's just going to
free up other resources to fund this
kind of stuff by the way at the time
when the US said don't don't do
terrorism with this the Iranian
president Ibrahim rizi said that Iran
was going to use the money however it
wanted to so it it's not it's not even
as though the us could say ah dratz they
got us again they they promised us they
did a pinky promise that they wouldn't
use it on terrorism and then they did
but we believed them no they told you
they said we're going to use this
exactly how we want to which is going to
be terrorism by the
way
now how how are we all to think about
this in the West A lot of people are
deeply invested in the Israel Palestine
conflict a lot of people are not a lot
of people don't particularly care they
don't want civilians to be killed and
they don't and they don't want our
country and other countries to be
brought into a global conflict so how
how do those kinds of people think about
this attack and this war that's about to
happen a good a good lens through which
to view this war is the lens of Karen AA
who is a Washington Post columnist she
once led the papers International
opinion section uh she retweeted two two
takes on Israel Palestine
the first one is what did you all think
decolonization meant Vibes papers essays
losers so she's this wo columnist former
head of an opinion section is is
cheering on Hamas and the rape of
Civilian women and the execution of
Civilian elderly and babies and just all
sorts of war crimes cheering it on and
everyone's attacking her for this
rightly so but
at the very least I give her points for
honesty because the the tweet that she
retweeted is exactly right all this talk
about decolonization which is a clinical
abstract euphemistic term that's always
what this meant decolonization always
meant kill civilians decolonization
always meant attack torture murder
civilians and take things by force not
by law that's always what it was and a
bunch of liberal White people uh
convince themselves you know
establishment Center leftists convince
themselves that no this would be a kind
of a peaceful thing man we're just look
this is this is a really sophisticated
Nuance view of world affairs that's not
it it was always going to be civilian
Bloodshed then the other tweet that she
retweeted was Karen
AA uh uh she retweeted Amy Saul who says
liberation self-determination and peace
for all oppressed plus colonized people
that's my
politics
even if you do not care about the Israel
Palestine conflict there are many people
who say look I have very little
connection to this region maybe I I like
the the holy land but I have never
visited the Holy Land I don't I I don't
have friends who live in this place I
don't really it doesn't interest
me it's very difficult not to see how
the pro Palestinian
argument applies to every Western person
as well as to the Jews because the pro
Palestinian argument is Liberation
self-determination peace for the
oppressed and the colonized we need
decolonization it's exactly the same
language that AOC uses to talk about us
it's exactly the same language that BLM
uses it's exactly the same language that
antifa uses so you might say I don't
have anything to do with Israel I don't
care about Israel I don't care about
Palestine or Gaza or any of these people
I don't want any of us to go over to war
there I don't of course none of us do
none of us want any of that but if
you're trying to figure out which side
you're on which side you're generally
more supportive of in this
war to me it is quite striking that all
of the all of the arguments for the pro-
Hamas Pro Palestine side are the exact
arguments that BLM and antifa and the
squad and all the rest of them make
against ordinary normal conservative
traditional
Americans there's a reason for that and
what deonis ation has meant to Hamas in
Israel is exactly what decolonization
means to AOC and the squad and BLM and
antifa right here in the USFA doesn't
look very good when you want to look
good you got to check out Jus cell right
now go to genucell.com NES everyone here
at the office loves the genus Cell Dark
Spot Corrector you might be asking what
this product even does well if you have
sunspots dark spots discoloration or dry
skin the genus Cell Dark Spot Corrector
will help those blemishes disappear
Kimberly from Youngstown Ohio says quote
my appearance has improved so much since
using genus cell I love all my genus
cell products and my skin looks younger
now it's your turn to feel like Kimberly
but hurry because this sale is ending
very soon take advantage of genus's most
popular package which includes the
Beloved Dark Spot Corrector this package
also includes Jus cell's classic under
eye treatment you will get all of these
products from a 70% off Jus cell so
confident in their products you can try
them yourself completely risk-free if
you know immediate results you will get
your money back it's simple go to Jus
cell.com
K wle start looking years even decades
younger tomorrow say hello to the very
best skin that you've ever had at Jus
cell.com that is jus.com
there are a lot of rumors flying around
in this war and no one really knows what
is true one of them and this was really
sad I saw this pop up on Twitter and I'm
ranking things by tragedy here obviously
the number one tragedy is that attack
the number two tragedy is the civilian
deaths in the war that will follow the
number three tragedy is the loss of the
world order and uh potential
restructuring of the international
order under that is the potential
destruction of works of art works of
culture sacred places we're talking
about the holy
land
and obviously we value human life above
all of these things
but but some some of these artifacts
some of the relics some of the
institutions in the Holy Land date back
a long time one of which is St por
furios Church in Gaza this is a church
that dates back to the early 5th Century
it was then rebuilt by Crusaders in the
12th century and there were reports
going around all day yesterday that the
Israelis bombed Gaza and destroyed the
church
where PE people were posting this left
and right and it it was genuinely tragic
you think no this church stood for 1600
years this very was one of the oldest
churches in the world and it just was
destroyed in this in this violence oh
that's that's so on top of everything
else that's so awful and
then the church responded and said no
we're fine the church it's a Greek
Orthodox
Church they they were posting on
Facebook they said no this news is wrong
the church is currently opening its
doors to receive refugees inside who
know knows I hope I pray it's not
destroyed in any of the coming violence
I was skeptical of this news story when
I saw it but the news was coming out so
so fast and it occurred to me oh right
that that is very good Hamas propaganda
that the church was destroyed because it
gets westerners and it gets Christians
to if not turn against the Israelis at
least to back off from the condemnation
of Hamas and the calls for destruction
in Gaza oh that's really good War
propaganda and who knows maybe it came
out of Iran maybe it came out of Hamas
maybe it was just some Grassroots kind
of effort but that is one example out of
a billion of propaganda fake news
stories that are going to fly
around
my chief recommendation when it comes to
analyzing these events is to be
extremely skeptical of any information
that you see swirling coming out of any
side about any aspect of this war double
check triple check everything propaganda
flies a lot faster in times of
war wars in the Middle East Wars around
the Holy Land are particularly tense
they involve basically every single
player on earth we were already on the
brink of World War III because of the
first major war in Europe breaking out
since World War
II the global order can collapse very
very quickly world wars have started for
a lot less than this be very careful of
the information you're seeing meanwhile
as the world order crumbles the United
Nations is focused on what they believe
really matters which is the plight of
been alone so but time
I'm with you turning back to domestic
politics RFK Jr as predicted over the
past couple of days announces he is
running not as a Democrat for president
anymore but as an independent we have to
acknowledge the truth we do think the
decaying infrastructure and record
record levels of suicide depression
addiction chronic disease we do face an
entrenched political corruption and an
inequality of wealth not seen in a
century but the good news is that people
like yourselves are finally fed
up
something something is stirring in US
that says it doesn't have to be this way
and that's why I'm here today I'm here
to declare myself an independent
candidate he is an independent candidate
for president and he's got doesn't seem
like a huge crowd there but a crowd
enough at least for the announcement uh
this is a smart move for Bobby Kennedy
Jr he was obviously not going to win the
Democrat nomination he's polling at 15%
among Democrats that's not enough to get
you there even if it were enough the
Democrat Party still has enough control
over its process that it can at least to
some degree overrule the voters it
wasn't going to happen so now he runs as
an independent some conservatives are
worried I'm not worried Bobby Kennedy I
think takes more votes many more votes
away from Joe Biden than he does from
Donald Trump some right-wingers kind of
like Bobby Kennedy because he was
against the coid vaccine that's pretty
much the only reason for conservatives
to support Bobby Kennedy he's
pro-abortion he's anti-gun he's
pro-immigration
he's he's a liberal he's a he's a
liberal Democrat on basically every
single issue except for Co vaccines he's
he's fanatic about global warming I I
don't think he's a terrible guy he's a
much better Democrat than most Democrats
out there but he's going to appeal to
moderate Democrats he's not going to
appeal mostly to conservatives center
right magga Republicans any of that I am
all for the Bobby Kennedy independent
run I do not think he is going to be
Ross pero I think he is going to be
Ralph nater and I am here for it we need
some renewal in our political order and
you need renewal in your home which is
why you got to check out Renewal by
Anderson right now text nolles to 200
300 for most homeowners window
replacement is not something they've
done before for many others it is not
something they want to do but rather
something they have to do have you put
off replacing the windows in your home
because it's too expensive well I've got
great news you can now get a free inhome
window consultation and a free quote
from Renewal by Anderson Renewal by
Anderson's signature service is
committed to giving you the best
customer experience possible supported
by the best people in the industry right
now Renewal by Anderson is offering a
free inhome or virtual consultation on
durable quality affordable windows or
patio doors for Zar down zero payments
and zero interest for one year text
nolles kwes to 200 300 for your free
consultation save 375 bucks off every
window and 750 bucks off every door
these savings will not last last long so
be sure to check it out I had a
carpenter write to me totally
unsolicited said when he goes into homes
the best work he sees is from Renewal by
Anderson text Nes kW to 2300 that is
nolles to 2300 texting privacy policy in
terms of conditions posted at text plan.
us texting enrolls for recurring
automated text marketing messages
message and datat may apply reply stop
to opt out go to windowappointment
now.com for full offer details faith
more Andrew clavin's talented daughter
though no relation has written a new
rendition of the age-old Christmas
classic A Christmas Carol except this
time it's with a K it's a modern Twist
on the story of eaner Scrooge except for
the female protagonist in a world where
boss babes are championed at the expense
of Family Faith is making the case that
having what matters is far better than
having it all Christmas Carol is now
available for pre-order order yours on
Amazon or wherever you get your books
today is Trump the inevitable Geo
nominee that's the question that Bobby
Kennedy is wondering that's the question
that Republicans are wondering right now
uh Ronda santis is making a bold move
one of the first really bold moves to
come out of his campaign and that is to
move a third of his campaign staff to
Iowa uh DeSantis is essentially gambling
his campaign now on Iowa third of the
campaign staff goes there he's got
around $5 million in available primary
funds in the war chest that's according
to New York Times report so Iowa going
to be that first in the nation contest
that sets the tone for the rest of the
race uh still even there Trump is above
49% in support according to rular
politics in Iowa he's 51% support in the
GOP Primary according to CBS News so
he's way way up not just nationally he's
way way up in Iowa two is this stupid
for disantis then no I don't think it's
stupid for
disantis I think this is is probably
desantis's best bet but that tells you
more about how the campaign is doing
than about
desantis's likelihood of beating Donald
Trump because Iowa does not predict the
Republican nominee Iowa has not
predicted the Republican nominee for
president in more than 20 years the last
time it happened was George W
bush uh
furthermore even even if it did predict
the Republican nominee he's not pulling
all that well to begin with
furthermore when candidates who get a
big hype start pulling resources out of
later States and focusing them all on
one or two early primary States that's
usually a sign that the campaign is
floundering and it's not going to go
very far Giuliani did that after
Giuliani was viewed as potentially a
front runner in 2008 and then he put it
all on Florida and it collapsed uh John
Huntsman who I personally love John
Huntsman uh he focused a lot of his
efforts on New Hampshire it didn't help
the campaign whatsoever this happens
time and time and time again but what
does disantis do his options are either
pull resources out of all of these
states try to get a good showing in at
least one of them and even if that
doesn't make him the nominee at least
he'll have had one state where he
performed pretty well in or drop out but
he can't drop out he's pot committed at
this point it's not like he can just
drop out make nice with Donald Trump
become the Vice Presidential nominee or
kind of go his own way and then come
back four years later he's in it so he
does appear to be largely backed into a
Corner if I were on his campaign I'd
probably have made this bet but it's not
the kind of bet you want to have to make
speaking of the
presidency this is a really this is a
really unfortunate
story Joe Biden's younger brother Frank
has just shown up naked on a gay porn
app good night everybody I think you
know on that kind of a story I don't
even want to go any further uh Frank
Biden now the second Biden to show up
naked on the internet
uh he's on this gay porn app I don't
even know which one it's called guys
with ion.com not not a very creative
title is it uh this is according to
dailymail.com they've got the naked
selfie so this wasn't a candid shot he
was taking it of himself uh Frank Biden
says I have absolutely no comment I
could care less I have first of all just
to pause there the phrase is I could not
care
less if you say I could care less that
means that you care
somewhat at least
so I don't mean to nitpick the grammar
that one drives me crazy though and it
actually might tell you a little
something about Biden's role in all of
this he says I could care less I haven't
even looked at it they must have hacked
my phone anything that is a revealing
picture of some kind is between Mindy
and me I guess his wife I really don't
want to start off my day this way
definitely didn't post it
anywhere maybe he was hacked people try
to hack our phones all the time even
just among conservative uh commentators
and activists and anyone with any public
profile so I wouldn't be surprised at
all if they're trying to hack the phone
of the brother of the president of the
United States the reason though that I'm
a little skeptical of the they hacked my
phone excuse is that this photo
apparently didn't just appear on guysi
ion.com it showed up in
2018 so it showed up before Joe was
President it showed up after Joe was in
the senate for almost 50 years it showed
up after Joe was the vice president it
showed up at the one period of Joe's
life when he was in private
life and before he was president and
then the it's just kind of surfacing now
uh regardless of whether Frank Biden is
a deeply deeply closed homosexual or if
he's just a victim of a hacking or
something my
takeaway my advice to
everybody stop taking naked pictures of
yourself stop it stop it whe it's
whether it's for your wife or your
husband or your boyfriend or your
girlfriend whether it's for some app
like this one a gay app or a straight
app or some kind of
polyamorous pan
gender otherwise imaginative kind of
what stop it nothing good will ever come
from you taking naked pictures of
yourself be normal stop being weird stop
being a weirdo weirdos take naked
pictures of themselves you should not
Endeavor to be like that you should
Endeavor to be normal good grief these
people speaking of responsible behavior
there's a report at I teased it on
Friday we'll get to it now gen Z is
drinking a lot less than other
Generations I was just on vacation
sipping a few salty dogs by by the pool
you know
not being very much like a Zoomer
according to this report from the
journal nearly a quarter of 18 to 29
year olds are more likely to smoke
cannabis compared to older Generations
that to me should be the headline of
this article because the headline of the
article and the whole thrust of it is
genz they're sober they're not drinking
the Millennials and the Gen xers and the
Boomers they're they're alcoholics but
the younger generation is getting sober
they're not getting sober they're just
getting intoxicated on other substances
and the substance they're getting
intoxicated on is marijuana which uh
older Generations are much less likely
to use and booze is better than pot is
what I'm saying I know this is going to
be controversial I know my chat is going
to explode with a bunch of people who
have the Grateful Dead playing in the
background who are you know just kind of
vibing out to the show and they're going
to say Michael how dare you say that
marijuana is a miracle drug it cures
everything every problem I ever had was
cured by marijuana I love it it's great
booze is terrible the minute you take
one smell of a glass of wine you're
going to just start going out and
beating your wife and neighbors and dogs
and shooting people and you don't and
you're going to hear all of this but
it's simply not the case uh Tucker
Carlson had a good argument on this not
that long ago Tucker said that this was
back when he was still on Fox the ruling
class they want us to to put down
tobacco and pick up marijuana so it's
not about lung health it's not about our
alvioli it's not about cancer risk or
anything like that it's simply about one
smoking substance over another tobacco
for all
its negative side effects it makes you
sharper makes you faster makes you more
focused it's the sort of thing you do
while you're working so you can work
faster and harder it's the sort of thing
that the manly men in in Mad Men were
doing marijuana Makes You duller Makes
You stupider makes you slower makes you
less funny makes you less ambitious
makes you want to eat more potato chips
okay so the regime they don't care about
your lungs don't care about your health
they just want you complacent and
stupid I think the same thing applies
here I'm not recommending that anyone
drink to excess ever but alcohol makes
you a little more sociable alcohol makes
you a little more chatty at party
alcohol livens you up it's a social
lubricant marijuana does the opposite
marijuana makes you more introverted
makes you kind of sit around pull back
into yourself makes you slower makes you
so if you got to pick one don't do
anything to excess but that's I don't I
do I know all the all the JZ all the
establishment Outlets they're probably
going to view this as a good thing I
don't view it as a good thing you have a
choice between a nice glass of red wine
and a
bong
civilization chooses the red wine now
we're going to turn away from the youths
for a second toward the older
generation I mentioned Rudy Giuliani
earlier Rudy Giuliani is suing Joe Biden
for defamation here's why it's a typical
New York Times malicious lie I do not
have an alcohol problem I have never had
an alcohol problem and the reason I told
you what I achieved is nobody could have
achieved that if they did when the hell
was I drinking I was working 24 hours a
day it's a big damn Lie by a newspaper
that's a disgrace and by a reporter who
covered me used to cover me very very uh
in a very glowing way and now is vicious
and mean in what she does thank you and
it it's my press
conference vicious and mean and if it
weren't for the protections that the
Press gets with times against Sullivan
I mean she should be sued for liable she
should also be thrown out of the
profession for being a damn liar but
that's okay so Rudy while explaining his
defamation suit against Biden talking
about how all these other people are
defaming him too the latest attack is
that Rudy's an alcoholic and Rudy has a
good counterargument to this which is
I'm extremely productive okay I was the
most successful mayor in the history of
New York I had a very successful legal
Consulting business after that I'm on TV
247 I was the lawyer to the sitting
president of the United States I give me
a break when would I have been drunk I
was on camera most of the time and even
if you think I'm eccentric I probably
wasn't drunk so he's saying this is a
specific defamatory claim and I'm going
to sue and I'm going to go Sue all the
way up to Joe Biden does Giuliani have a
case a defamation case against Joe or
any of the bidens yes he does and not
just on something like you know a claim
of being an alcoholic Hunter Biden
during one of his most infamous
interviews during the 2020
race claimed that Rudy Giuliani was a
wacko conspiracy theorist pedaling a
pack of lies that Hunter Biden had taken
money on behalf of the Biden family from
crooked people around the world do you
regret being on the board to begin with
no I don't regret being on the board
what I regret is is not taking into
account that there would be a Rudy
Giuliani and a president of the United
States that would be listening to this
this ridiculous conspiracy idea which
has again been completely debunked by
everyone it's been completely debunked I
wasn't getting money from Ukraine and
China and shaking down people on behalf
of my father the big guy who Rudy found
the laptop he found my laptop he found
my messages I know it says I gave a
bunch of money to my dad and I shook
down foreigners including the Chinese
Communist party for tens of millions of
dollars but no I don't that's all fake
it's all been
debunked then it was rebunk and it then
it was just proven to be true and you
know when you look at a a claim like hey
you drink too much that's probably not
going to hold up in a defamation lawsuit
but if Rudy is suing Joe Biden for
saying you know you're a Putin stooge
you're a Russian propaganda
you're that that really might and I I
encourage this lawsuit one because I
have a real soft spot for Rudy Giuliani
because he's the greatest mayor in the
history of New York but two because Joe
Biden needs to be held to account for
his career for his half century of
defamatory lies this is a guy who lies
with with such ease that I don't think
he even understands what the truth is
anymore this is a guy who lied about the
the the man man who accidentally in this
horrible accidental car accident killed
his wife killed Joe Biden's wife and
Biden had acknowledged the man he wasn't
drunk he was it was just a horrible
horrible accident and the Man I mean he
just was racked with guilt for the rest
of his life and then Biden on the
campaign Trail decides he's going to
start claiming that the man was a drunk
driver this is this is Joe Biden a man
who speaking to audiences will just make
up facts about his son about his career
about things he said about things he's
voted on beliefs he H he just lies with
impunity and so I'm all for it Rudy baby
take this guy to the cleaners please my
favorite comment on Friday is from user
SR8 dl5 wl1 Z that sounds like an Elon
Musk child that is that is a very long
and intricate name Michaels transitions
he says from serious topics to selling
pumpkin spice and genus cell is freaking
hilarious never a dull moment in nolles
nation L thank you very much I'm glad to
hear that because you know what Life
Goes On Life Goes On It must even amid
tragedy even amid fear even you know
life just goes on and we got to keep on
lighting those pumpkin spice candles
find little bits of uh humor in there
while we can and uh sufficient to today
is the uh misery and apprehension and
anxiety thereof uh speaking of Crime and
Punishment there is
[Music]
a
speaking of woke activists someone even
woker than that complaining about laws
against
pedophiles uh Mark Millie former
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff he
has retired and he's retired with a
parting shot at Donald Trump what uh
Millie has said is quote you say we in
uniform are unique we are unique among
the world's armies we are unique among
the world's militaries we we don't take
an oath to a country we don't take an
oath to a tribe we don't take an oath to
a religion we don't take an oath to a
king or a queen or a tyrant or a
dictator and we don't take an oath to a
wannabe
dictator and the wannabe dictator
presumably is U Donald Trump this guy
goes on and he pin and he whines just
like he was preining and whining about
white rage and while while he was
defending his his view that the US
military that our troops
should not spend all of their time
training to kill the enemy but they
should spend their time studying
critical race theory that they should
spend their time studying radical
leftist ideology to understand the roots
of so-called white rage this guy is a
joke I'm glad he's out of the military
and there are a lot more Mark Millies
out there that need to go my takeaway
from from Millie's Parting Shot is that
Senator Tommy tuberville is a hero
because Senator Tommy tuberville alone
is holding up promotions in the US
military he the US military the Pentagon
has insisted on a new policy uh through
which they're going to pay for service
members to kill their children after
roie Wade was overruled after certain
States reverted to laws protecting
babies the Pentagon decided okay if you
are stationed in a state that won't let
you kill your babies we're going to pay
you to go out of state to go kill your
babies and Tommy tuille said whoa what
where did this come from no way get rid
of this policy Pentagon and the Pentagon
said who the hell do you think you are
you're just a US senator you're just a
member of one of the three branches of
government you're just a civilian
elected to oversee and run the
government by the people of this country
and we're not going to let you tell us
what to do so there's been a hold up
here and Tommy tuberville says okay well
if you're not going to if you're not
going to play ball then I'm not going to
give you your promotions I'm not going
to allow you to keep bumping up all your
generals and he has been under so much
pressure by democrats and some
Republicans who say we need military
Fitness we need a fighting force you've
got the first Ranger war in Europe since
World War II you've got now War breaking
out in the Middle East this we need
those generals yeah I agree but it's not
Tommy tuberville that that is preventing
the military from having its generals
it's the
Pentagon if the Pentagon top brass
believes that Killing American infants
is more important than being able to
have generals to go kill our enemies
that's the pentagon's
problem we got a very simple trade here
you're so afraid about National Security
you're so afraid about the worst
breaking out around the world okay yeah
we I have some fear about that too I I
want some caution there too so stop
killing little American children and you
get your generals oh that Deal's too
harsh for you okay then here we are I
guess we're not going to be a very fit
fighting force in that case anyway clear
Mark Millie's gone good that's a you
know what I call that I call that a good
start now today even though it's my
first day back I didn't have Monday on
so it's Tuesday the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become a member use code nles canw has a
checkout for two months free on all
annual
[Music]
plans